[Music]
in the more you know news submitted by
all Skeet Skeet Oh never gets old
memories make me cry
no one knows what you're talking about
all this man trumpets here's what your
sleeping position says about your
personnel oh I wanna know I want to know
what sleeper are you what's the bright
side me too but I like that I'm a side
sleeper but I have to like bein like
feet open no you're like this no I don't
know I at least I feel comfortable
falling asleep in the fetal position and
then you wake up like this I know in
your in your sleep
yeah they're like dead alarms like [ __ ]
what do I do this well it's goodest I go
sleep like this sometimes I'm born to
bed last night and it's like twelve or
whatever and Nicki's completely dead
asleep I climb in bed Mickey looks at me
and she and she always wakes up and
she's delirious and part of being with
Mickey is I have to know that she's
gonna say something nuts but because she
doesn't want to be like appear stupid
even if she says something completely
incoherent I'll have to agree with her
otherwise she it's [ __ ] passed like a
dream Nicky gets pissed so like last
night she goes she goes hey honey do you
want to get King ten if it happens what
if do you want to get King tenth if it
happens and I was like Joker yeah no
nothing it makes no [ __ ] sense I've
had her say to me before I understand
like yeah well we'll get the pavement
are we gonna get the pavement I'm like
no honey what he talked about she said
oh are you are you serious like that and
then she like rolls over and then I'm
like oh my god I'm gonna fight like her
no no she doesn't wake up with anger but
she yeah her eyes are open she sounds
like Nicki right in the morning this
year
no [ __ ] no she's like good morning now
[ __ ] and I'm like I thought we were the
final night go to sleep scare yeah I
should have just said yes to the
pavement [ __ ] Soto King 10 I agreed
though now I just agreed no matter what
the [ __ ] we baby even the King 11
okay so I said I said yeah and she's
like okay she'll talk to me but she
won't remember that my new [ __ ] is he
gets a butthurt even though I've told
him I'm like I can have a full-on
conversation I can not remember and then
he gets really sad because of whatever I
said that I don't remember
you're finally nice to him maybe it
wasn't real so all those things that you
were saying that we're so sweet it's not
true oh my god that's probably true yeah
I'm sorry alright so this there was a
study conducted by one poll on behalf of
Lisa sleep
and so they examined the sleeping
positions and personality traits of 2000
Americans and so they've pretty much
narrowed it down to three types of
sleepers back sleepers side sleepers and
stomach sleepers I'm a back sleeper side
sleeper from a side to stomach on the
side side side I can't sleep on my back
yeah so they're saying back sleepers
they take the least amount of time to
fall asleep which averages to twenty
point one minute
mine's twenty six twenty minutes I'm
five seconds yeah yeah three miles is a
long time really that bad as an average
that's not bad
twenty minutes to go to sleep it takes
me forever to go but like when you're
actually trying like okay now I'm going
to close my eyes going to sleep and I'm
20 minutes later if I wake up in the
middle night I'm [ __ ] that's what I'm
really fun then it could take hours for
you to fall back so we're going to bed I
concur 2.5 seconds like a [ __ ]
Ferrari engine
so it's the complete opposite of view
though but I'm working I'm working on
god damn it Steve you're [ __ ] me up
in this video god I can't win I'm coming
after you alright so bagpipers get the
least amount of sleep at night average
five point twenty eight hours they get
five nights of perfect sleep a month
they're most likely to be an early bird
which came out to forty two point eighty
one percent that's for sure early bird
for sure most likely to be an introvert
33 point 54 person that's Bart very
introverted side sleepers
most of us here um they take the most
amount of time to fall asleep which is
twenty three point eighty eight minutes
they get the most amount of sleep at
night or a night which is five point
seventy eight hours eight hours five
point seventy eight hours then they get
six nights of perfect sleep a month they
are most likely to be a night owl which
is thirty two point sixty five percent
they're most likely to be in extroverts
which is twenty eight point forty four
presenting tonight sleeping is supposed
to be the healthiest - it's the most
natural way of is it I always feel like
my bones get me sooo I heard those back
I heard it was back and then it was side
to side sleeping on air many we're
studying hunter-gatherers like in Africa
and in the Amazon and they would like
they were just seeing how they sleep and
everyone just sleeps on the side like
this and then they'll use different ways
like that there's a whole study on it
yeah societies like so yeah I put one
little here and then I hold another
pillow mmm I don't think the greens were
hunters or gatherers I think they just
chilled back and had beer and though
yeah a hell of a job guys bring it over
here
all right side sleepers I'm gonna wait
stomach sleepers they take 22 point 51
minutes to fall asleep they get five
point sixty five hours of sleep a night
they get six nights of perfect sleep a
month they're most likely to be both an
early bird and a night owl 33 point 94%
and they're most likely to be an
ambivert what
what is that burglar sounds like Ambrose
most likely to be missing yeah they're
sleeping early desirable for sex
trafficking it's like they balance an
extrovert and introvert person it's just
everything so then am i an ambivert no I
mean you're an introvert like a
[ __ ]
you're an introverted already and she's
way more than me which is crazy
Oh was your percentage on the minor 76 I
want to take that 76 introvert yeah does
it help you understand more by yourself
like in a positive way especially a
relationship - yeah yeah okay yeah we're
complete opposites like absolutely but
help me understand who she is now and
then now instead of trying to force her
in the way into how I feel lots more me
or me trying to understand y'all or
instead of me trying to understand her
through my school of thought I could
understand her through her school only
took seven years pretty good pretty good
pretty good
pretty damn dude one decade not better
technically 11 both its end on time we
don't like to rush things right yeah
that's true I could do they like to age
it they like to age things they like to
taking that test you know how they are
like different categories like in the
colors and stuff yeah what colors were
yours oh the stupid one cuz when Casey
and I took ours we were both in the
green category ours having like labels
like names and yeah those was adventure
and I was the architect I always liked
campaigner oh and then yours was a what
a mediator hmm oh that makes sense yeah
yeah yeah because Casey's personality is
very agreeable in a way where he likes
to keep peace yeah as much as possible
yeah yeah
mediator mm-hmm campaigner a campaigner
there saying that we like we like to
think of the big picture and we're very
outgoing and like our outgoing
personality draws in a lot of people so
we tend to have a lot of friends I don't
know there was a lot of things where I'm
like I don't that sounds like me I don't
know but you're pretty extroverted like
you you just jump in a conversation a
lot just naturally you know I feel like
I've changed my like my personality has
turn more introvert
yeah kind of death I know I feel that
way I get like less interested in making
new friends I like talking to people I'm
just like what's the point you feel old
I'm just like I'd rather spend time with
the people I already know that I like I
feel that's how that's how I felt and
then I started to dislike the people
that I liked oh and then I'm like now I
need to go make new friends see it's
like I'm just kidding that's that we
don't have ityou anywhere anymore
yeah I know I know
I promote my percentage no but I am more
extroverted in the scale but the one
that trip me out the most was Casey was
96% introverted why did that throw you
off I can't believe it wasn't a hundred
he's pretty mean to pick on I bet you
Casey would be happy with watching
movies and cooking steak every [ __ ]
day in his house no cuz I'm very
introverted that amount of times I asked
Casey Casey to come out I'm already like
I can't believe I feel like the
extrovert in this relationship right you
know and I'm usually very introverted I
feel bad saying no to people that asked
me out all [ __ ] time I guess I'm very
I watched the movie American Beauty
where the kids film in the bag blowing
and I'm like that's my find Casey a
camera and a thing to film that's an
observation I'm just agreeing yeah he's
very grateful he's too introverted but
you can't even see him that's how
interpreted is kind of like that the
myers-briggs uh testa it's pretty cool
no but we were going through this whole
sleeper personality stuff too and it was
really accurate for both me and Casey
cuz he was a back sleeper or what are
you a back sleeper to my side sleeper do
you not go fast yeah yeah immediately
with you so think oh well I think me too
I'm surprised the average is only like
five point seven hours and come on five
point seven up here pull it pulls s
wheelchair this is fun
five point IFRIC I didn't realize you
guys were such
extra I mean introverts though until
recently because of the line of work
we're in and and you guys are just you
have to be social I think that's what I
think that's why I like because I know
socializing is part of work when I go
and socialize I see it as work and I'm
doing it as work so it becomes
exhausting yeah whereas people that are
extrovert I think since it's more
natural to them they see like picture
that's like the happy hour part of the
job or after five where you go drink and
hang out with five to eight they don't
they go okay off the clock having fun
socializing with my friends for me five
to eight is [ __ ] I'm just working
overtime now yeah that's so true like
for me if I'm working like I rather do
like the more mundane like like
organizing and like kind of the things I
can do by myself for my jobs like those
are like way more fun and then like the
things where I'm like maybe like right
now definitely a little more strenuous
but you know the crazy thing is that I
did I never took you guys for that and I
known you guys for so long and I didn't
know you were suffering inside that's a
difference oh wait what about when you
guys have like an expo where you meet
like hundreds of waited I'm yeah I'm
dying they're not all introverts are
suffering right it's like you're just
it's just only in those social
situations right yeah well for me like
with that example I love the connection
that I get to have between people um and
it's a one-on-one because it's like
they're your friends right that your
supporter so I'm very humbled by it so I
like making that connection I try to
connect as hard as I can but after that
at the end of it I need to be at home
for like the next four days yeah
what'd you is that you're very
introverted and yet you're such a good
extroverted mama bear to people like
like even you know I mean like you like
you've helped Nikki a lot behind the
scenes I don't think a lot of people
even know that like but that stuff that
like you reached out to her it's not
like it's like hey can you talk to Nikki
or anything like you an introvert
reached out to Nikki and like when she
needed help it like stuff like that I
think cuz I'm so it's so hard for me to
connect it's so hard for me to let
people into my world but once I let them
in like your [ __ ] are not going anyway
yeah
that makes sense I can't go anywhere
whoa Matt Mauck no I think like the idea
of extrovert and introvert gets skewed a
lot because people don't people like
think introverts are all shy or whatever
but all it means is where you get your
energy right do humans energize you or
do they exhaust exhaust and for
extrovert like me like humans are great
entertainment like I love that energy
even if it's bad energy or whatever
energy like and a lot of it doesn't
exhaust me like it actually charges me
up because I'm laughing at them or
whatever and it doesn't make me feel
well okay so for example what I'm trying
to what I'm trying to point out is that
yeah but people watch because introverts
they see it they internalize it they
actually get their feelings hurt by a
lot of things and then they go this is
too [ __ ] much I got to get the [ __ ]
out of here it's bothering me we're an
extrovert we'll go oh my god that's what
happened interesting drama wow that's
something cool and then you walk away
and it's not like you're heartless or
whatever but it's just that we can
compartmentalize a lot of these
experiences with human beings and in
that energy that you get in a crowd in a
group and and that is what charges me up
and if I'm staying at home all day I
feel like I just I go crazy yeah I think
it's almost like having a sweet tooth I
think when you're an extrovert it's like
you can eat all the sweets in the world
for me like it all it takes is one or
two humans and power God already like
when things are over sweet yeah like a
cookie eat another muffin you're all
it's too much so for me like it's like
my sweet tooth for humans it's like if I
meet one new person I'm like oh flavor
overload I gotta go back home and rinse
my mouth and then and and just chill out
yeah what's great about this guy too
Casey is that he no because you you are
you are quieter but when you talk I
swear to god you can hear a pin drop
because everyone hasn't heard you talk
and then when you're talking it's like
oh yeah I think every word of yours gets
listened to when you're talking
especially in our writers rooms because
it's like okay yeah like like I'm like
I'm like grabbing onto every word like I
like I'm like climbing on them with you
it sounds like you're his number
fan-dude I love him and cut
I put his chin in my butt he does have a
big car that kind of chin he's got a big
dick
[Music]
[Music]